in the French city of Leon dark winter
nights have just become much brighter
for for evenings that fête des lumières
lighting up the city center over 50
light installations bathed buildings
streets squares and parks in a warm glow
Logitech children you'll see it's very
pretty
the lights make things look nice and new
works like this help you discover new
artists yeah it's real beautiful like
and it's really impressive just like the
whole city is lit up for the festival
it takes me back to my childhood the
lights
sonography and all of the music and
ambience an ambiance many of the
installations don't just look nice they
also tell stories on these facades
everything revolves around France's most
famous hand puppet Guinean he was
created by a silk weaver here in Leon in
the early 19th century
Belgian keyhole Parnell and her artists
collective from Portugal turned Guignol
into an illuminated figure for their
project he's a symbol a bit like the
Eiffel Tower in Paris the people who are
going to visit Leon are going to the
little Guinea on Museum and see a bit of
puppet theater is he's a marionette who
has become a symbol which goes way
beyond Lyon
so when they asked us to work on this
marionette we said wow that's a big
responsibility city we've become
immersed and poor the animation artists
from aku bow always tried to create a
connection to the places where they work
and with the people who live there for
their puppet theater projection they
shot footage with schoolchildren at
Leon's puppet Museum in the film the
children who go to see the puppet
theater have themselves become
marionettes they exchanged their heads
and their bodies with the marionettes so
the children have to be dressed and made
up like the marionette the fête des
lumières a long tradition in Lyon
it started out as a religious festival
in the 17th century the people of Lyon
pray to the Virgin Mary to protect them
from the plague and because the city was
spared
Lyon citizens gave thanks to her each
December a tradition that continues to
this day on December 8th people in Dior
usually put candles by their windows to
honor the Virgin Mary
they brought a different kind of light
to Leon the Lumiere brothers with their
cinematograph they created the motion
picture film camera in the 1890s
the Museu do confluence is devoting a
show to them this year and this
attraction of the light festival is also
bringing cinematic history back to Leon
on the walls of buildings at the plaster
table artist Nataniel peak or lets her
daughter dive into famous films as an
animated character
Jogja pasta force I've been drawn to the
cinema ever since I was very young my
father repaired 35 millimeter film
projectors and I saw between 200 and 300
films between the ages of 8 and 10 so
movies have always enriched my life le
multi-million novella the light shows
can be seen all over Leon but the post
office
two sisters stumble into the world of a
video game at the cities roman
ampitheater there's a projection of a
magical flying horse and this
illuminated flower garden is an oasis of
calm in the heart of the city center
this is the third showing for Cornell's
puppet theatre she wants to see how its
received
he's one of the actual liberal are
reacting exactly the way we hoped they
would because the puppet theater is the
theater in which there are lot of oohs
and ahhs and children calling out things
and I've already seen people in the
crowds were just as surprised and
astonished a festival of light and a
wealth of history two million people are
expected to marvel at this mixture of
tradition and modern light art